Tổng thống ino nho này sẽ ông Bravo suyên tổ ngầm lắm tổ mi hà cho biết
các khu vực truyền đạo xin hoa trọng đến gửi biếm trọng bởi lúc và sản ổn đất thử dành qua
ngọt thế phải gần thứ 2 đến 8 tháng để khu vực xin hoa bình thường sau thảm qua kênh hơn một hình hồi trên mang
phát biểu tại qua học nữa cá, ông Bravo nói, đồng các đại két tại bá tệnh chục thải nặng đã được chuyện cái
đồng thời thử nhận Washington có phục không thể hằng thành trong bây giờ ngắn
chính phủ dự kiện xây dựng hàng trăm của nhà tham để hỗ trợ nizzon phải sớt tảm và lấy nhánh việc khu vực hạ tần kyd yếu
dù nhận được đình hiểu hỗ trợ từ nhiều cuo ra, tổng thống Bravo của cũng khẳng định
tình thấy đã được kiểm soát và ino này xia đủ khả năng tự ứng phó
theo số liệu chính thức, các trận người lớn dò sải khẩn gây ra từ quay thăm hiểu một
đà khiến ít nhất một khiến khẩm chăm bán bí gửi thịt mang tại xin hoa trọng
hải trăm lệ sáng lời và mất tích khiến thái thử phá hình dụng
có dân cứ và bộ hằng chủ kênh người phải dựng mọi người
rồi chức có thể chỉ bị tài thiết tổ thiệu, lên tối bà phải mục tiền của là Mỹ
các tổ chức môi trường cho rằng nạn phá xin linh quan đến khai thật của các khá quán đã làm trong trong thêm
tất lọng gửi lột, chính phủ dự như xia đã tạm bị chi hoa đất của một số phân nghiệp
bị gạo bộ bí phạm và hiểu cầu tiên hành kìm góan môi trường
đông thơi kẹn báo sẽ tu hồi dây phép, nếu phát hiện xa pham trong tất cả quán lý